country's opioid epidemic is putting
pharmaceutical companies under new
scrutiny Delaware is one of the states
that recently filed a lawsuit against
pharmaceutical against the
pharmaceutical industry joining 13
others the state's attorney general is
targeting the entire opioid supply chain
from manufacturers to distributors and
chain drugstores but now the industry is
pushing back Julianna Goldman is in
Washington Juliana good morning good
morning well more than 30 state
attorneys general are investigating and
negotiating with the pharmaceutical
industry to try and reach a settlement
over the opioid crisis but a number of
AG's have lost patience and have
actually left the group to sue opioid
manufacturers directly and now there's a
high-stakes campaign to get them to drop
their cases and make sure more states
don't sue so they can contain potential
damages may I can enjoy every day that I
live I can really enjoy myself that was
the message to 15,000 doctors in 1998
from Purdue Pharma the company that made
thirty five billion dollars from the
sales of the painkiller oxycontin the
rate of addiction amongst pain patients
who are treated by doctors is much less
than 1 percent the company says it
corrected its marketing and pled guilty
to misbranding in 2007 but Ohio's
Attorney General Mike DeWine says the
company continued deceptive marketing
through 2014 if you go back 20 years in
Ohio you can see the number of pain meds
prescribed in Ohio start going up like
that last May DeWine sued Purdue and
four other pharmaceutical manufacturers
I would love for Purdue Pharma and these
other drug companies to follow me around
just one day give me one day and I'll
show you what you have done to the
people in the state of Ohio
Purdue recently tried to persuade DeWine
to drop Ohio's lawsuit and negotiate
instead writing litigation takes years
and the costs for both sides are
significant there's a lot of stake for
them and so they've been very aggressive
they've lured up they have hired
lobbyists and they've opened their war
chests donations from drug companies to
political associations for state AG's
have risen in the pass
three years totaling almost $700,000 to
Democrats and over 1.7 million to
Republicans professor Paul nollette
studies state government so you have
some of the very companies that have
manufactured opioids are either under
active investigation or potentially
under investigation donating tens of
thousands even hundreds of thousands of
dollars to these AG organizations the
Republican AG Association told us they
have an obligation to the people to hear
from all sides their Democratic
counterpart said they also hear from a
wide variety of voices the contributions
are legal but they allow companies to
gain access to the AG's at exclusive
meetings golf outings and high-end
dinners opioid manufacturers and
distributors spent over a hundred
thousand dollars to partially sponsor
this meeting in San Francisco that was
really something else the the opening
dinner last night and at a meeting in
may to opioid companies who had given
the Democratic AG Association a combined
$65,000 got to speak on a panel at this
hotel in Oregon and told a group that
they were not responsible for the opioid
crisis according to several attendees
well there are nationwide rules for
congressional lobbyists there aren't any
when it comes to lobbying state AG's
those lobbyists don't have to say how
much they're being paid or who they meet
with Gail Purdue Pharma declined our
request for an on-camera interview but
told us it is deeply troubled by the
opioid crisis and is committed to
working collaboratively to help solve it
why Julie on a lot of questions and not
enough answers thank you very much